[Music]
let me bring in our candace zone so we
welcome to spectator
tv she's a conservative commentator
author of blackout founder of blexit
it's an organization urging black
americans to stop
voting democrat which they do in huge
numbers
uh you might know from her days as the
communications director of turning point
candace owns welcome to spectator tv
um is it not time now
for mr trump to concede and move on
no uh and i i strongly disagree
with freddie's assessment that the
american people want this election to be
over with it's quite the opposite you
had 73 million people
uh voting for donald j trump and all of
these people right now are being gaslit
by the media
there was once upon a time where the
media would tell the people story
right so right now we've just had the
media uh telling their own version of
events not speaking to any americans who
are
presenting tons of evidence they send it
to me of their own their own ballots uh
not being cast not being counted
uh people showing you that their dead
relatives have voted in this election
this was one of the most insane
elections that we've ever had
mind you the media the same very same
media who prepped us
all year saying that this election we're
not going to figure out the results it's
going to be unlike any election we've
ever had
because of cobit 19 and male invalids
it's going to take weeks and weeks and
weeks
for us to be able to count now that same
exact media is saying well never mind
trump just needs to concede
and we had an election where we all went
to bed at 2am trump was winning by a lot
and then suddenly we woke up and we were
told that the exact opposite happened
they stopped counting
and suddenly there was a massive dump of
ballots and joe biden was in the lead
everything about this feels fraudulent
and to say you should just certify the
election because the media is ready to
move on which is what we're really
getting at the media
is ready to move on the media has been
ready to move on from trump honestly
since he won
in 2016. right wrong but you called the
election
fraudulent and talk about the media but
even donald trump's
own lawyers in key states
are not alleging fraud in arizona
and pennsylvania his own lawyers have
said we're not alleging fraud
so it's not just the media the fact is
you haven't got the evidence to show
fraud in any kind of great scale
which of trump's lawyers because you're
you're making that law or i'll give you
two his lawyer in arizona when asked by
the judge said
we are not alleging fraud or the
stealing of the election we're talking
about quote good faith or
errors that's donald trump's lawyer or
in the case in montgomery county
pennsylvania
the judge asked the lawyer are you
alleging fraud here
no we are not alleging fraud okay so the
error
okay if the if we're talking about the
word fraud and you're and you're
reducing it down to the word fraud what
we have
realized that is that these errors that
seem to be happening these accidental
errors where they transfer votes
from trump to joe biden only seem to be
happening one way so whether you want to
say
it was human error which is what the
dominion voting systems is arguing at
this point in america
that it was all human error and
something happened and someone pressed
the wrong button
fine but the results are fraudulent to
the american people you cannot just move
on
when 73 million people do not trust the
election
process and do not trust the votes and
it was done in a year where you
transformed
the election process you guys would
don't do this in the uk you guys don't
calculate
and do an electronic system they don't
do this in canada they force this
they they force this in america because
of cobit 19.
and if you go back and look at my
rhetoric you're the one one that used
the word fraudulent
yes fraudulent and fraud mean the same
thing
i give you two examples of his own
lawyers not
alleging fraud in two key states where
did the divine
dominion voting machine where what
evidence is presented that that's made a
difference
well i i'm not sydney powell so you're
you're speaking to me as if i'm
you know i'm not the person who
presented dominion voting systems as an
issue or an error
i raised it in michigan in michigan i'm
saying that
the votes were changed 6 000 people were
voted that who voted for donald j
trump got changed to joe biden um so
that happened in america
and they've come out and they said that
was a human who pressed the wrong button
you know but
are you talking about antrim county in
michigan i'm not sure uh
it could be antrim county guess correct
what happened was the original report in
antrim county was wrong these votes
hadn't been moved
it was the report of the voting that was
wrong not the voting machine that was
right and it was right
no that was dominion voting systems that
was their argument but the other people
are saying that it was a huge
dominion voting system is saying it was
a human error and sydney powell and
trump's campaign is saying it was not a
human error that the system was designed
to be able to do this
and this is what he's talking about when
sidney powell is saying that they have
more evidence
that they're willing to present and
rather than allow them and afford them
the right to do this the entire
mainstream media is saying just move on
it's not here why not just allow them
this is what our system allows for
allow the due process to go through why
are we trying to sweep this under the
rug and move on and say
well we don't have any evidence yet so
it needs to be closed again this is the
same media that told us this election
was going to take months and months and
months to count
including joe biden himself joe biden
hillary clinton
hillary clinton boldly said that joe
biden if he lost should not concede
so i don't understand how the media can
then just flip and say you know what the
exact opposite and gaslight all the
american people who they've been
conditioning to believe
that this election was going to take
months to transform i mean to call
okay i want i want to move on but i
don't it's not a question i would just
say
before we do sweeping things under the
carpet it's it's a question
of looking very carefully at all the
evidence people who take your side
present and then discovering that in
most cases it doesn't stand
up to scrutiny that doesn't mean
sweeping it under
the carpet but indulge me
let's assume that i'm right that at some
stage mr trump does have to concede
joe biden is the next president the 46th
president of the united states
will donald trump run again do you think
i don't know that's a good question um i
i would i would hope you would run again
i mean i
i don't think that any person this is
going to be
a bad election result no matter what
because as you're seeing in recent
polling there are 73 million people who
do not believe that this
um election was executed in good faith
and we have been saying this since long
before the election i've been saying
this since march
the idea of transforming the entire
election system
in one year and expecting states to be
able to do with this um and having so
many people's voices
censored right people that are speaking
out about their own election fraud
stories are right now being censored
by the big tech i just don't think it's
going to it's going to be a very testy
time in america and it already has been
for the last four years
um so perhaps he will run if he did
obviously i would support him i think he
should
um but it's wrong and i'll tell you what
is fraudulent is all of the mainstream
media and the tech people
calling president biden i'm calling
former vice president biden the
president-elect
that is incorrect it is wrong language
he should be called a presidential
candidate this election has not been
called by the states
okay let's try and keep we keep on track
here because i don't got too much
much time mark our card and
on this now the of let's again assume mr
trump doesn't run
i mean i perfectly understand he may
well but let's assume he doesn't
tell us what will the battle for the
soul of the gop be like
it's going to have to stick with what's
been dubbed as trumpism
uh the gop has completely changed it's
not it's no longer the
establishment republican party and when
i say that i'm talking about the john
mccain republican party it's completely
transformed
over the last four years for the better
it's become more inclusive
what you can see by looking at uh the
early exit polling numbers
you know hispanics largely and i think
36 percent voted for donald j
trump this election uh black uh women
and doubled their support for donald
trump
black men voted 18 for trump so despite
all of the rhetoric of
trying to smear and libel him as a
racist the party has actually become
incredibly more inclusive um and that's
in large part
because donald j trump was a a more
cultural figure
and what i mean by that um is that he
was able to communicate his message in a
more effective way
and he felt more attainable to the
american people and i get that he's a
you know he's a boisterous busty
billionaire from new york
uh but he does when he speaks to people
he's very much a blue collar and able to
relate to them in a different way
and i think that's good let's be clear
what what is you saying because
it's interesting what you said you're
saying that even without mr trump and
maybe actually be with mr trump we don't
know but even without mr trump
the republican party will still to at
least a substantial degree
room become and remain a trumpian party
absolutely without without question and
if that's the case candace
who in the absence of mr trump perhaps
he's going off to start his own
tv station or whatever it is he wants to
do
um in the absence of mr trump what kind
of republicans today
do you think best embody these trumpian
values um there are a lot of different
elements of trump so if you're talking
about just being a person
who you know doesn't bulk when the
mainstream media is on their backs
somebody like ron desantis right i mean
he has he has stood firm
in the copen 19 christie gnome um in
south dakota
uh has been has stood firm on her
policies despite the media creating a
pressure campaign against her on covet
19.
um so what we're really talking about is
someone who does not bend to the will of
the mainstream media because the
mainstream media does not represent
americans at this moment
and i would and i would i would even go
so far to say the mainstream media
doesn't represent
uh people in the uk as well right they
completely missed it may be the case but
though i've actually managed to work the
mainstream media into every
answer i and i i get that you're a part
of the mainstream media and it can be
offensive but you have to you have to
call it accurately you know
you you understand they just keep
misdiagnosing the people that they are
supposed to be representing and rather
than
get an answer without the mainstream
media being involved uh
it seems to me i i mean i know what you
you are it's clear what you want
uh and you're certainly not alone in
that that even without mr trump
you think that mr trump has transformed
the republican party it's a very
different party
not just from the old east coast country
club republican party
but also even from the the goldwater
reagan west coast
republican party as well and you think
he's made a big change there
i understand that but you will know
there are still plenty of people in the
republican party
that see this as their chance if mr
trump departs
to go back to not a country club
republican party
but maybe a more reaganized kind of a
republican party
so there is going to be a battle for the
soul of the republican party is there
not
i don't believe so i think the
republican party has actually never been
more united
um and there was definitely a fracturing
when he first hit the stage in 2015
um and there were many people that never
you know the never trump parade and
republicans
did not stand behind them but all of
those republicans stood behind him this
election cycle
um so you know despite i won't i won't
say mainstream media but despite
pictions depictions the republican party
uh is is actually very much together in
this moment and i don't think anybody
wants to go backwards let me
bring freddie in then i'll come back and
finish with you candace uh
uh freddie what do you make of what
you've heard well i
i mean i hate to be accused of siding
with the mainstream media i've always
tried
uh not to god you're out of this well
now
it is i it's just i hate i've been
busted and my closet never trumpism has
been exposed
uh but i do i i do think it's very
interesting about what happens to the
republican party after trump and i do
think we have to have this conversation
despite
the ongoing contestation i mean i'm
just interested in how much you can
withdraw trump from the scene
and still have the movement he created
and i think one of his failings as a
leader and i hope candace doesn't object
too much to this
is that he hasn't established a movement
that can work politically he hasn't
taken over washington in the way that he
could have done he hasn't even taken
over the republican party in the way
that he could have done and so when he
goes if he goes
you will see this revert to the mean and
i think it will fail i think
the bush-era republican party is
destined to fail
but trump hasn't established a party
that can go forward without him and i
wonder whether it can because
one of the reasons trump is loved and i
agree with candace he is really loved um
it's because of his flaws it's because
of his failings so a lot of people when
they talk about trumpism without trump
they say they imagine a sort of a
trump-like person a national populist
who sort of doesn't have his flaws
doesn't send out nasty tweets
but but the tweets and and the trump the
element of the donald
is crucial to trumpism i wonder how it
can survive and i would like to put it
to candice that
i think the likely way in which it
survives is with donald trump jr running
in 2024 perhaps with candace owens
as his veep is
i would i actually agree very much with
your assessment and
i would all only say that if you look at
america
just through the lens of the past people
usually need a break from the from the
family
um so i don't know that donald trump jr
following donald j
trump works um but then again if people
feel like
they were not vindicated in the 2020
election cycle maybe it does but you are
correct but it's going to have to be
somebody
um who is a fighter and at the end of
the day that is that there are those are
the characteristics of donald j
trump like he's a fighter excuse my cat
has apparently jumped into this
um but uh it is yeah i i would
totally people have always asked me you
know am i going to run am i going to
jump in and throw my hat in the ring and
i always say the same thing trump said
20 years ago if i felt that my country
needed me
um and that i had to do what i would
i have no desires to do it i don't think
it's a fun job i think it's a sacrifice
and that too many people want to go in
for vain reasons
uh when in fact it's an incredibly
difficult job to lead a country
that's a brilliantly political answer
yeah yeah
it sounds to me you're definitely
running candace that's uh you got that
answer down to a pat
listen we watched this election the
so-called young country
it seemed to be you had to be 75 plus
before you were allowed to be a
candidate
or a candidate succeeded donald trump uh
joe biden indeed who were the likely
alternatives
elizabeth warren bernie sanders i mean
all these people that combined ages come
to about 2.5 million years
uh isn't it time for a break and your
party your republican party and i
appreciate you're an insurgent in the
republican party
but it's too male pale and stale as well
you need to reach out and get a lot more
voters you
you did badly among a lot of the women's
vote you need more ethnic votes
you need to be younger i mean i'm i
think of all that and i do
who am i and you need a true believer if
you take the view
the the trumpian way is still the future
you need a true believer
so i think of all that and i look at you
on my zoom screen here
and i think who takes every box
candizone
just announce you're running today on
spectator tv
i love that i i love the encouragement
um you know i'm i'm a different kind of
person i've never been one of those
people
that has a plan everyone says to me what
are you gonna do in five years ten years
i'm i'm a big believer that you you have
plans and god laughs
um and in four years
[Laughter]
well played um you know obviously
there's there's a big energy for that
and and people really want to see that
but
i'm being honest when i say that every
time i sit down with my husband
uh and talk about that i just say you
know if if
it comes to that and i thought that my
country needed me i would do it but i i
genuinely do believe that as a sacrifice
i love my life as it is
i get to say what i believe
unapologetically um and and i live a
great life i'm happily married
with a kid on the way so um the idea of
sitting down and plotting and planning
to become the president united states to
me there's just something about that
that's incredibly narcissistic and i
just
i don't have that character tree but
when i if i do announce i will
definitively do it on spectator tv
we're going to hold you uh to that i
mean
everything you say the more i'm
convinced i mean even the baby's going
to arrive in plenty of time
perfect little half black half white
baby half english half american it's
gonna be great
long before you need to start the
primary campaign trail
that'll be perfect and you're married to
a brit and it's about time there was a
brit back in the white house as well
that can only make for an improvement if
you don't do that we might burn it down
again as we did in 1812
so it's all going well listen whether
you run or not
i hope you really come back and see us
on spectator tv
uh we wish you all the best for the
coming christmas season
and good luck with the baby
[Music]
you